gentlemen we're live the spanish did a
census uh
yeah i'm just getting a photo
cool uh the spanish did a sense
live today with matt zeller who uh if
you're not familiar with matt zeller i
think what was it three four months ago
where
you went viral all over the place
afghanistan i think
brian williams had you on interesting
brian williams just recently stepped
down and he had joanna you were talking
about afghanistan with the decision they
made to leave afghanistan was right
and you went off and the next thing you
know you and i spoke i think the day
after two days later and then
from there we're seeing what's happened
to afghanistan now so before if some
people don't know your background matt
if you don't mind taking a quick second
and get give everybody your background
sure uh i enlisted after 9 11.
um
my family comes from a long line of
people who signed up to fight when this
country needs them my grandpa joined the
navy right after
pearl harbor for example so 911 for me
was like our generation's pearl harbor i
signed up to serve in the military ended
up getting recruited in the cia
um did a tour or two overseas in
afghanistan
and uh
yeah um i've been intimately involved in
helping the afghans get out of
afghanistan now for the better part of a
decade because the only reason i'm
sitting here talking to you
is because my afghan interpreter saved
my life in a battle 13 years ago when he
shot and killed two taliban who were
about to kill me
and then wasn't there a story done on
that seven years ago with bbc or
something like caroline you can come in
it's it's all over the place yeah yeah
yeah there's i think everybody at this
point has told that story yeah matt
question for you so from that moment
when you when you spoke and you
uh called out
just to kind of bring people up to date
if they didn't see it here's what i
remember about what you said you got on
you said we send them the plans we've
been telling them what to do we've been
explaining to them how to leave
nobody responded back nobody called us
back you said you voted for biden you
said this is a guy you're not a trump
guy you voted for biden you supported
his
philosophy i knocked doors in
philadelphia for him that's what i'm
saying so and then you are saying we
can't go on
lying about what we're doing and saying
we did exactly what we're supposed to be
doing so
but but this is what i did you so this
morning i'm leaving the gym and i'm
sitting there saying let me see what how
much how much media has matt zeller
gotten since those comments he made so i
went on no joke i went on and i looked
at your stuff last 90 days because that
was about four months ago three or four
months ago
so i looked there is nothing on you on
media the last 30 days nothing with any
major media i don't see anything with
msnbc i don't think i don't see anything
with cnn i don't see anything with fox
and everybody had you on for that week
that you were on so
who did you piss off where people don't
want to hear your thoughts apparently
everybody okay uh tell me why though
tell me why everybody's pissed off i
know for a fact that i've been at i've
been told specifically the the
administration won't meet with me or any
group that has a meeting because i put
them on blast on national television
because they were lying to the american
people because as you said we on the 9th
of february 2021
a group that i'm a part of called the
association of wartime allies wrote a
report
uh
highlighting
calling to attention to the fact that
afghanistan was going to collapse it was
going to collapse faster than washington
could respond and that it was going to
necessitate the largest airlift in human
history in order to get the vulnerable
afghans who had served alongside us who
were in need of rescue out of the
country and we were trying to call
attention that it needed to begin at
that moment because we understood
that biden at that point was up against
what we called the trump surrender they
had they had surrendered afghanistan to
the taliban in doha in 2020 uh there was
an obligation that we were going to be
out of the country by the first of may
you know biden blew past that deadline
and said well we'll extend it to august
but the reality was is that from where
we were standing in february we saw
there was maybe 90 days on the clock and
we had to start acting then so i you're
right i knocked i was i'm a proud
democrat i ran for office as a democrat
i was the democratic nominee for a
district in new york state for congress
in 2010.
i
thought that given all everything i've
done for the party and my connections
the fact that these are friends of mine
i i know jake sullivan okay i know
people in the white house i these are
people i i socialize with in washington
so i thought if i send them a private
email i'm not putting this out you know
on the new york times i'm not going on
cnn i'm not even going on a podcast or a
blog post this was a private email so
before you publicly called out you kind
of gave them
gave them months yeah well this was i
mean you were part of a think tank that
put together yes you actively
yeah you did step by step logistically
how you would do the we wrote a white
paper when no one paid attention to it
then we took it to uh like a proper
think tank that i'm a part of called the
truman project and we said let's make
this a thing let's let's put some like
organizational support behind it make it
look professional
maybe they're just not paying attention
because it came from me individually and
not from a group of people that they
would listen to more
what we ended up learning was that they
just weren't interested in the truth
yeah they weren't interested in why
though why why would they not be because
there is an arrogance in this
administration that they think they know
better and there's a there is honestly
they were more concerned about the
optics of chaos than they were about
doing the hard thing this is an
administration that seems to be afraid
of making the tough decisions they're
afraid of making optics of chaos the the
hard call right so they were more
concerned about the narrative on
television being oh this is bad
then actually having to take roll the
hard six and say you know what we're
gonna take something that might not be
politically possibly popular here just
to clarify and that's an interesting
point that you make because they seem to
have that issue 100 with foreign policy
yes domestic policy they have no problem
telling people to shut up and do what
you're told correct so it makes no sense
it's schizophrenic in its nature right
it seems like there's there's the
foreign policy aspect of this white
house that is very afraid of the world
and is very afraid of how the american
people are going to react to whatever
they do and so they choose to just
simply do nothing and by doing nothing
they actually engender the very worst
outcome that they fear themselves i'm
seeding too much ground on autocrats for
sure so so go from there go because
right now if you look at the news you're
not really hearing as much about
afghanistan as you know three months ago
you're going too soon i've been see i've
been busy i don't just so what's going
on behind closing i don't just sit
around and wait for the media to call me
yeah so the last major media appearance
i did was on the 14th of september
andrea mitchell had me on her show
on uh i had just spent that morning
watching secretary blinken get hammered
by members of the house of
representatives and the day before he
had been before the senate and it was a
remember them it was abundantly clear to
anybody who watched we weren't getting
answers yeah we were getting kabuki
right we were they were using
afghanistan as a cudgel both sides were
retreating into their narrative
democrats were saying we did no wrong
republicans were saying you're the worst
thing ever and nobody was actually
getting to the bottom of what went wrong
and how do we prevent it from ever
happening again but with blinking the
worst part about that was he he seemed
as interested in the process he could he
was like it was performative he was just
there to like check a box right this is
the time that i come and get yelled at
and then this is it right that's how it
seemed to be it's like okay i've done my
two two days in the hot seat
and that was afghanistan yeah 20 years
2.2 trillion dollars
over 2600 americans killed in action
over 21 000 americans injured not
counting the 66 000 plus afghan
military members not even the civilians
who died in this war you don't just do
two days of hearings so i said on tv
she asked you know what do you think of
this and i just i spoke the truth i said
i think what was needed was a 911 style
commission that was properly constituted
to
in a bipartisan or even nonpartisan
nature investigate the entirety of the
afghan that exist it it will now because
guess what for the last three months i
have been very quietly working this
issue so tammy duckworth saw me on on
andrea mitchell and called me up uh and
said we agree we're writing something
called the afghan war commission act of
2021 we need your help
they then had me call up uh some
republican members of the senate that i
know
uh and get them to jump on board to
co-sign and co-sponsor this this piece
of legislation and then i did the same
thing in the house of representatives so
much for those social circles buddy it
passed the house two weeks ago uh it's
in what's called the conference package
of the the the national defense
authorization act so the house has
already passed their version of the law
that funds the defense department for
the next year the senate is supposed to
be passing it at some point this week
it's considered non-controversial right
so it is going to absolutely pass when
the senate votes on this thing it's part
of the language that everyone already
agrees on that it's simply just they're
waiting for a vote as soon as the senate
votes on it it goes to the president's
desk and it will be signed and what this
is going to do is going to transform the
discussion on afghanistan because this
commission will exist for the next four
years
it is going to be it's modeled after the
911 commission so it's eight republicans
eight democrats
no one can be elected and be on the
commission at the same time you can't
hold federal office in any way no one
can be elected and be on the commission
at the same time correct so there's
nobody who's using it to like current
yeah politically granted
you're not using it to just get sound
bites to help with your next election
it is going to have this is what there's
never been anything like this in
american history it has the purview to
investigate the entirety of the afghan
war all 20 years
all four administrations all four white
houses all four intelligence communities
all four defense departments all four
people not happy about this and who's
happy about that i i would imagine that
if you served in uh in washington in the
last 20 years and worked on afghanistan
you're probably going to get called by
the commission at some point to testify
some people are going to be thrilled at
that some people are going to absolutely
not want to give me names like who's not
going to be a happy birthday i am i'm
i'm positive probably that jake sullivan
in the white house uh and mark and um
for example ron klein the current chief
of staff probably are not going to enjoy
their time i'm absolutely positive the
trump people are not going to enjoy
their time particularly pompeo in front
of this commission right because this
commission's going to get to the bottom
of things it's going to figure out what
went wrong where did the war pivot why
did we end up losing because this isn't
what winning looks like most importantly
at least for me as a veteran
my hope is that what comes out of this
is policy and procedures that prevents
the chaos that we saw at the end of a
war from ever happening and we have to
fundamentally change how we go to and
come home from war
so so let me let me give you uh a
cynical citizen's perspective on that i
mean that that's
it sounds good but at the same time for
my adult life i've lived and i've never
once seen
any politician outside of maybe ron
blagojevich ever held accountable for
anything that they've ever done true
i've never seen anybody in any capacity
that was a civilian contractor be held
accountable for anything they've done i
think i read once the out of the 2.2
trillion that we spent over 2 trillion
dollars went to civilian contractors i
mean that's i mean there's a lot of
people that became mega wealthy off of
this oh yeah and they profited immensely
off of this and we live in a society
where rich people don't go to jail so
what what does this hope to accomplish i
hear this and i say okay there's another
couple billion dollars about to be spent
on government lawyers there's another
you know years of of hand-wringing that
that's going to be done and at the end
of it nobody goes to jail at the end of
it nobody's held accountable it's the
panama papers it's i mean you know you
who went to jail for the panama papers
julian assange the guy who the guy who
was right about everything so i i mean
listen it's it's i'm not trying to
to dissuade you in any way from this no
i couldn't yeah nor could i but i just
fro from our perspective it's like man
yeah what do we do as citizens because
these people are never held accountable
this is what we do i know that i look i
get it accountability begins with an
investigation it begins with shedding
light on what went wrong
so few americans actually know what
happened in afghanistan right
that
that this is where that accountability
begins that word that you use
accountability is so important it's what
veterans talk about all the time right
because at my level in the military if i
had [ __ ] up i go to jail right i go to
the brig i get i get court-martialed i
can i can be punished
a general messes up they get to retire
and then go get a sit on a board
somewhere we bomb and we can't
kill seven people and they're like it's
an honest mistake as a buddy of mine
said the defense department regrets to
inform that your entire family has been
killed due to processes and procedures
not being properly followed like
come on yeah come on i i had a i had a i
had a buddy of mine and i had a buddy of
mine in afghanistan
i brought he held his like his feet to
the fire because of a firefight in which
you'd call in an airstrike that ended up
killing some civilians right and it was
it was a legitimate airstrike and his
feet was held in the fire because they
weren't they wanted to make absolutely
sure that all the right things were
considered before they dropped these
bombs
these drone strikes that's the
difference now with warfare man if you
don't have people on the ground
identifying people you're just trying to
rely on some kid over in nellis air
force base in nevada to try to figure
out if the dude there is i mean they
killed the guy in afghanistan we're
talking about right now because he was
packing water jugs into his car
that's why he was killed it looked like
he was packing what they thought were
explosives that's called a war crime
isn't it it is it is and yet we don't we
don't hold anybody accountable this is
how we hold so what you're working on
right now is that public info do people
know that you're working on this or it's
private
this is gonna be public i mean i'm
telling you now first person i there
where there will be a big media blitz
about this coming out i'm gonna be
tooting my horn trust me uh because i i
put my my head down i i i had to get
this done this is actually how [ __ ] gets
done
uh in this country is these commissions
like think about it this way
my buddy paul reichoff who is one of the
founders of an organization called the
iraq and afghan veterans of america
paul uh is an iraq war vet and he's
currently teaching a class at amherst
college his alma mater on 9 11. and
everyone in the class was born after 9
11 which to me is mind boggling yeah
that's interesting he said the most
invaluable teaching tool he has is the
911 commission report
i don't know if you've ever read it but
it's actually the most easily readable
government document ever made it reads
like a book it doesn't read like a
boring government document
we all lived through 9 11. i'm sure
for a lot of us myself included i can it
feels like i'm back there yesterday if i
talk about it right but my daughter who
was born in 2012
has no clue this is going to be an
invaluable resource for her there's
going to come a time in our country's
history where there are going to be
americans who who look at afghanistan
the same way some of us look at like
world war ii in korea and vietnam we
don't have a contextual experience with
it it's something that our parents and
grandparents did it's something we read
about right
i'm hoping that the report that comes
out of this is as invaluable to future
generations as the 9 11 commission
because again we've never done a
post-mortem at the end of a war like
this we've never sat down in the
military we call it an after action
review the joke would be nobody's going
home until everybody gives me three
positives and negatives right
right that that is that is what we're
gonna be doing now we're gonna be doing
a proper after action review of
everything that went right and wrong in
the war and this is good business right
because this helps us prepare for the
next war too yeah so so so go to it
though go to though in regards to
uh what we heard so the moment uh
afghanistan was taking place three four
months you saw the interviews that was
going on with the taliban and you saw
how you know the taliban interviews were
well they're saying they're going to be
good to women they're saying right
they're saying they're going to treat
them
they're saying you know when you would
see the interviews one of the taliban
would say you were talking about 20
years ago things have changed i just saw
six changes just saw 60 minutes this
weekend well i saw that yeah
we are taking care of women that's an
old thing you're thinking about and then
you hear the stories where a video you
see a 55 year old 60 year old man taking
a 12 year old girl to be his wife
because the mom and dad are giving her
up because they need money for food and
you say wait a minute that doesn't match
what you just said and being a middle
eastern having been born and raised in
iran heard a lot of those stories saw
those stories personally saying yeah
this is what could happen in a place
like that from your perspective having
contacts up there having people up there
what's going on in afghanistan right now
it is the nightmare we predicted it
would be so women have no place in
society they're trapped at home
uh compulsory education for women ends
the minute they reach puberty they're
not allowed to go to schools
um
so cbs lying
cbs might be talking like the taliban
like i think like north korea you go to
north korea right yeah a lot of people
go to north korea they get like the the
official tour they take you to all the
things that are open
everything else is actually closed you
don't get to really see the poverty
behind the scenes it's the same in the
taliban there's the dime tour that they
take foreign media on
you go and actually talk to the people
in the country though and people are
starving
as we predicted this winter is going to
kill more people through starvation and
exposure than the taliban could ever
possibly hope to with their bombs and
bullets and the reason why is because
the international community fed and
fueled afghanistan for the last 20 years
afghanistan is holistically dependent on
imports to feed and survive its
population right the taliban have no
international contact or support they
don't have to know how to manage the
economy so what they've done is they
have completely become dependent on
pakistan
they're selling off u.s made military
equipment to pakistan to try to feed
themselves what aid they are getting
from the world food program i can show
you right now if you want um this is i
got a
this is uh sent to me two days ago
um
here i'll show you a picture um
the taliban are refusing to give out
food aid to anybody other than taliban
fighters so if you are here this is sent
to me by a source of afghanistan so it's
a picture let me air drop it to him so i
can put it on the screen sure so it's
similar to the horror stories that we've
heard of like mogadishu back in the 90s
it's just as bad like people are selling
their kids
vt macbook pro kids people are selling
their kids to to feed themselves there's
there's a picture on on social media
this morning of a guy literally selling
his shoes in kabul to try to buy food
for his kids
um there is uh the bbc had an article
today no new york post had an article
today about uh an afghan woman who sold
one of her twins to help buy food for
the other one i mean people are making
selling to who and for what like other
people people selling people yeah sold
one of her twins yeah
so that she could buy food for the other
one it's in the new york post this
morning um but this picture that you're
putting up uh it's mario i don't know
why tyler's pointing out mario's picture
it's uh give me a second i'm finding it
it's uh this was taken by a source i
have in afghanistan help him out it
shows um
there it is wait on go back down to the
right bottom right bottom
all right here we go all right so those
are the taliban they're standing in
front of world food program uh and
unaids so that's that's that's actual
food and then winter you know blankets
and everything that comes from the
united nations via the world food
program the taliban in this voter are
distributing it in i believe this is in
helmand or kandahar and um what my
source who was in the room was telling
me is that the taliban were saying that
this is only for their people if you
fought again if you didn't fight with
them or for them your source is in the
room yes taking that photo
uh and what he was being told was that
because they were basically you had to
prove that you fought with the taliban
to get this eight they can so there's a
trust me i i've i've been begging the us
government to make a deal because these
people are transactional you know our
food and fuel for their people but let
me read something to you let me read
something but apparently by the way
that's not diplomatically allowed we
don't we don't put conditions on food
aid even though they put conditions on
who they distribute well taliban pleads
with washington to show mercy and
compassion and release 10 billion
dollars in frozen funds when it seized
control of afghanistan afghanistan's
foreign minister amir khan mutahi said
the funds would help millions of
countries citizens that are in desperate
need he also claimed afghanistan's new
taliban rulers
are committed in principle to education
and jobs for girls and women and mark
departure for their previous time in
power we saw a history of oppression and
human rights accuses mutaki comments are
not the first time he made a plea for
the funds from afghanistan's central
bank to be released however in october
deputy united states treasury secretary
wali adeyamo told the u.s senate
committee that he saw no situation in
which the taliban would be allowed to
access the reserves what's the
likelihood of these guys getting the
reserves never okay all right so that's
good news if they're not going to get
the reserves so even the current
administration is not going to release
this current administration i i honestly
couldn't tell you what a trump
administration would do i i think he is
such
a
[ __ ] when it comes to this stuff that
he that he might actually think that he
could get a deal with them and give them
the money thinking that somehow it's
going to lead to better or whatever
who's a [ __ ] trump you think trump's a
bigger [ __ ] when it comes to foreign
policy absolutely they surrendered
afghanistan to the taliban the deal they
signed in doha
that's why the commission's so important
you can't just look at one part of
afghanistan you have to look at the
whole narrative and everything changes
after doha the taliban were high-fiving
each other in the room do you get that
they literally high-fived each other
after pompeo signed the deal because
they realized that they had won the deal
that we signed obligated us to pull all
of our contract support from the afghan
military everything we used to we did
all of their maintenance on their
aircraft i have friends of mine who are
afghan army special forces that are now
fighting resistance in ponchir and what
they told me was that they were in the
middle of a battle when all of a sudden
their air support just disappeared it
just went away there was no one flying
helicopters their intelligence went down
their communications went down why
because all of the contractors that were
actually providing those services like
u.s contractors that were contracted to
the afghan military under the deal we
side with the taliban had to be pulled
by july
there was we signed a surrender
agreement he signed that i don't care
how popular he might be about anything
else when it comes to afghanistan that
man surrendered the country to the
taliban so that so it would be more
accurate in your mind to consider this a
retreat another withdrawal is that i
don't know what you would call no this
wasn't whatever it just happened in in
august is beyond retreat it's a fiasco
that was a collapse
that that was a complete and total
abandonment of a country and that was
why we were trying to warn about we saw
all of this coming and we understood
that the only way you were going to
properly prevent
the chaos that you ended up experiencing
in the waning days of august was if we
had begun this evacuation in the middle
of winter when we controlled every
single airfield in the country when we
still had 2500 troops that the taliban
were afraid of yeah that they wouldn't
engage with right
because they understood that if they
escalated violence it was going to be
returned to a war that they understood
that they were winning at that point
look the one time i ever got to talk to
a member of the taliban was 2008. we had
just gotten into a battle that morning
um the taliban had taken on an afghan
police force that we had been training
and these guys had just gotten back from
like their their training so they were
actually pretty proficient at that point
they hadn't sold off all their weapons
and equipment at that point
um
taliban engages this unit
the afghan police end up killing most of
them by the time we're able to get to
the police they've actually executed
they had captured a bunch of these guys
live and they'd shot most of them in the
back of the head all but one guy
so i get this guy
we explain to the afghans that they
can't kill him that he's a he is now a
prisoner of war he has rights and he has
to come with us for questioning because
he's more valuable alive so i i take
this guy over and he we're now waiting
for a helicopter to pick him up and take
him away
and i realized i get a chance to talk to
the taliban i've never seen my enemy up
close i finally get a chance to talk to
this guy
so i sit down as close as i am to you
and
i take off my helmet
i he looks at me he's terrified he's in
flex cuffs right
and so i i make the universal symbol of
do you want something to drink and eat
he nods so i have some food and water
brought over and then i take a sip of
the water and i eat a bit of the food to
show him it's not poison and he can
trust me and then i make the universal
symbol do you want a cigarette same
thing i i light up a cigarette my mouth
take a drag show that it's not poison
hand it to him
and then as he's sitting there and he's
smoking a cigarette and he's drinking
water and he's eating some food and he
kind of calms down a little bit i asked
him i said can i ask you a question
when was the last time you had something
to eat today
and he said actually i haven't eaten in
two days
i said really do you understand that my
country's flying in crab legs from
alaska tonight and steak because it's
tuesday and that's how they feed us on
tuesday but you haven't eaten in two
days i said do you know how many bullets
you had on your person when we captured
you
he shook his head no i said i counted
your weapon you had eight bullets in
your weapon eight i have 300 just in
magazines on my chest alone there's
another 20 000 rounds in my truck right
i said do you have an air force no he
said you have artillery well we have
some mortars but i said what happens if
if you if i injure you do you have a
doctor or a hospital that comes and gets
you goes no unless we can get back to
pakistan we probably die i said do you
understand then that if you hurt me my
government is going to spare no expense
to make sure i can come back here and
kill you i have an air force brother i
got artillery i got better armament i
got better arms i'm better fed i'm
better equipped why in the hell are you
fighting me because i'm not here for
your women and i'm not here to convert
you away from islam that you've been
told i'm just here to make sure that
your country isn't used to one day
attack mine again and maybe possibly
give your kids a better chance so why
are you fighting me i'm not your enemy
this guy
who had a quranic education meaning he
went to a madrasa and he memorized the
quran as his schooling
sits in front of me
takes a drag on his cigarette
points at my watch and says
you americans have all the watches
we have all the time
this was 2008.
i knew at that moment we were going to
lose i knew at that moment he understood
how to better articulate their strategy
for victory than we ever were able to in
20 years in afghanistan i challenge you
to find what the definition the u.s
government definition of victory in the
war was it does not exist i looked
donald rumsfeld actually said out loud
he had no idea what he was doing there
and he didn't know how to define the
enemy the closest we could get to w and
that might have been the most honest
answer anybody ever said in government
the closest i ever heard was it was the
absence of al-qaeda and the taliban well
the
in the absence of an ideology once it
embodied in one person you can't defeat
it i want to i want to address something
here because you went through a lot of
different things there and i want to
kind of bring you back a little bit so
number one powerful story it is a
powerful story you have the watches we
have the time absolutely it tells you
who has leverage because it's a story of
patience okay it's outlast we're going
to outlast you and eventually we'll flip
on you and we'll get what we want well
i'll plead you but but this is the point
i want to make to you so number one you
said trump is what word did you call him
he said he's a sweetheart he's he's
brilliant he's a genius what was the
word used i forgot okay that's the word
you use and you said because he pretty
much gave him a what that we're gonna
you know by july the contracts all this
other subjects you're the worst deal
you're gonna leave a little bit out
though you'll leave a little bit out
worse listen you sound like the the the
part that i'm going to push you give you
a little bit of pushback here's the
following
why is it
that the one thing obama and biden have
in common
everything
bad that happened during their
administration was bush's fault and
trump's fault why is that i don't
understand why why was it with
everything bad thing that happened in
trump's administration was obama's fault
but that's what that's important for
every american president what you're
doing then what you're doing is you're
playing to that so set that part aside
because the agreement if you look let me
finish i'll listen to you for 10 minutes
the agreement was
yes here's the contract
in july but it was also we leave
properly in may in the right sequence
the biggest challenge with here is
trump's not the president anymore so you
can't say oh it's trump's watch it is
not on trump's watch they can sit there
and say whatever they want to say about
this guy trump he was this he was that
he was this he's a negotiator he enjoys
it i think he's a guy that gets a kick
out of sitting there and he thinks he
can outsmart some of these guys you
can't outsmart shady people and the
taliban you're not sitting down with
business people this is not like
business men and women that you're
dealing with law and order and rules and
guidelines and all these different
regulations that you got to deal with
they don't give a [ __ ] about law and
order you're not dealing with people
that are reasonable like you so i agree
with you on that side you don't go you
know the whole famous line with the
reagan what was famous line with reagan
you we don't negotiate with
terrorists that's a famous line okay
well he did
there's no reason to negotiate there
however
bring it to today
biden has all these people around him
you claim you listen to your generals
you got millie when they went through
that whole thing nobody answered
anything they were afraid to blame biden
they were afraid to take responsibility
because their careers was on it people
are just kind of sitting there saying it
was as if everybody was walking on
eggshells and we learned nothing about
what happened so maybe the july
agreement was a negotiation but i don't
put trump as a dummy
because when when people sit there and
try to underestimate this guy would be
in a dummy i don't think anybody we've
had as a president the last 30 40 years
has more experience negotiating with
others in any kind of capacity than this
guy does in the area of negotiation now
does he have foreign policy negotiation
experience like some of these other guys
we've had no obama was a one-term
senator how much experience does a guy
have none
bush lineage he comes with a lot of
experiences one phone call away from
colin a guy that was a former director
of cia you know what he's gonna get from
that guy he's gonna get some kind of
counsel and he's been in that life his
entire life he's had drinks food dinner
with some of the most powerful people in
the world so he's a phone call away from
anybody right so i get bush i get senior
because of prescott you know the
grandfather uh i don't even get uh
clinton but clinton maybe a little bit
of experience with governor yeah
i get that i give it to him but uh biden
dude 43 years did you hear what he said
in oh wait about leaving afghanistan but
wait a minute do you remember what he
said in oh wait about it i was there
okay i i work he said if we ever leave
we cannot leave equipment behind we
cannot do this do you understand this is
billions of dollars don't you know the
old adage the exact exact opposite thing
don't you know the old saying in
washington show me a foreign policy
issue joe biden's been a part of and
i'll show you with the no the the line
is show me a foreign policy issue and
i'll show you an example at which joe
biden's been wrong like joe biden in
washington is always considered to never
underestimate joe biden's ability to
[ __ ] things up barack obama i i was i i
worked for the central intelligence
agency during the obama administration
in the bush administration and i worked
on afghanistan i i specifically was part
of the debate for what's called the
search okay
at that time the vice president biden
was the biggest proponent of something
we called ct light counter terrorism
light the idea was that instead of so
stan mcchrystal wanted this surge of a
hundred thousand troops in afghanistan
and i understood why because at that
point you have to understand at that
point all of the actual like fighting
prowessness in the united states
military is in iraq
let me give you an example in
afghanistan where i was um the taliban
figured out that uh if you could you you
basically could stop our movement if you
blew up our vehicles right and they
figured out how to make more and more
increasingly powerful bombs out of
fertilizer and gasoline and so they we
we joked that they had the radio shack
solution to the war they could blow up a
1.3 million dollar vehicle
with about 20 bucks worth of fertilizer
and gasoline right i mean
the
economics of that are just not
sustainable
so
what ended up happening was was we got
orders from our higher headquarters came
down and said we're sick and tired like
for example my unit was the first unit
ever to be issued was called an mrap a
mine resistant ambush protected vehicle
again these cost 1.3 million dollars per
chassis okay per chassis
the entire what's the what what's the
gdp of afghanistan uh i'd have to look
it up i mean i'm sure i'm sure i'm sure
the mrap budget probably was the gdp of
afghanistan but
we were issued four of these in april of
four
as of the first of may three of them
were destroyed the taliban blew three of
them up in five days where's the taliban
getting support from man because
pakistan russia iran
there's no way they're figuring this out
but well actually they were really smart
they had mobile training teams that went
around and experimented on us and
actually figured out that how to like
embed these things underneath the road
they use the road against us they
basically would put these things stacked
up in a v shape in basically boxes and
then whatever's happening is they put it
in a culvert so it's like where a stream
undergoes underneath the road it's like
a tiny little bridge you stack you box
you basically pack the culvert with
explosives and what ends up happening is
the vehicle drives over the culvert
there's an explosion that happens the
explosion isn't what kills everybody
it's the force and it's all the volume
of the road coming up and then flipping
the vehicle that's what was killing
people
so
i tell you all this
um because
it came down from our higher
headquarters about mid-summer 2008 we're
sick and tired of losing vehicles and
people
we have
in that order probably yeah we have
these the these engineering assets that
are called route clearance patrols
they're these big you think the vehicles
we drive are big and expensive theirs
are way bigger and way more expensive
and they're designed specifically to go
out and they they clear the path in
front of you they clear the whole road
of roadside bombs
we had three of these packages for like
three of these route clearance units for
the whole country in 2008. do you
understand how long
missions then back up because you're
waiting for one of these three assets to
be available so what mccrystal is saying
is i need everything from iraq there's
only so many of these types of equipment
in the us military most of them are
currently in iraq i want them brought to
afghanistan in such large numbers that
we can basically go back out and re-win
the afghan war because what a lot of
people don't realize was that the
taliban basically went to ranger school
over 2006 to 2007 and by 2008 had fought
us to a standstill and so mcchrystal
comes back and reports all this and says
i need a hundred thousand troops it's
the only way we're going to turn the
tide and obama is weighing the decision
about whether to do this now in obama's
ear is the vice president and he's
saying uh-uh i want that's the wrong
move we need to go a completely
different direction we need to do
something called counter-terrorism light
what we need to do is we need to
actually draw down our footprint we need
to reduce the number of troops in
afghanistan down to about at that point
it was around twenty thousand thirty
thousand eagles we need to get down to
about five to ten they need to be all
special operations and intelligence
troops we shouldn't have a big military
footprint we should be doing targeted
strikes specifically on al qaeda and
taliban leadership and that should be
our only presence and he pushed this
hard and obama chose to go with what we
called the middle option which was not
necessarily the surge
and not counter-terrorism light he
surged by an additional 30 to 40 000
forces it didn't work like a politician
yeah he had so the
this is but biden by the way the reason
i'm bringing this has been in the back
of the biden's head since that but this
is what you got to understand and this
is where i think america needs to
understand this is where our journalism
in this moment is failing us yes because
if we believe the hunter bot in emails
if we believe that he's that the big guy
is getting tens of millions of dollars
from chinese corporations from pakistani
corporations from ukrainian russian
corporations while this is happening
he's advocating against the people who
are fighting our own he's advocating
he's doing business for at the very
least doing business with and for the
very people who are fighting against our
own troops in a proxy war and this guy
is now the president united states of
america
i'm not there's no way to make an
allegation about that there's a lot of
you know uh there's a lot of correlation
there you know correlation isn't
causality but it's worth investigating
man seeing okay who exactly was paying
him how much money how much influence
did he have and how much influence did
they have supporting the enemy of
america at that time now i now in
fairness to anybody listening my
personal bias is i don't think we should
have ever been in afghanistan i don't
think we should have ever been in iraq i
think the patriot act is the single
worst thing that's ever befallen planet
earth from a geopolitical standpoint
okay uh i think donald rumsfeld is one
of the most evil human beings to ever
walk the face of the earth and i find it
hilarious that i marched against no
blood for oil in college and now dick
cheney and and the cheneys are team
biden and now everybody on the left in
america is a war hawk
you know how how thing times have
changed in 20 years blows my mind
you know but
in your estimation and you're passionate
about this and first of all thank you so
much for your service and i'm ha i'm
glad a guy like you is on our side
how do we you said that the economics
are unsustainable the economics of
imperialism are unsustainable how you
you have to decimate an entire country
then you have to occupy it for
generations
you you know so the
the concept of going in as a peacekeeper
and setting these places up
you don't you america we we the
revolution we didn't beat britain we
just outlasted them we made it we waited
until it was unpopular enough at home
and they were like these are our cousins
let them have the place the war of 1812
they came back and kicked the [ __ ] out
of us and then thank god napoleon got
got antsy and said i'm going to fight
otherwise we'd still be british again
and then vietnam over and over and over
the economics of imperialism unless
you're going to go in on some von klaus
switch [ __ ] and just mow everything to
dust and start over you can't do this
anymore you can't fight these wars
they're unsustainable which is why this
commission is so important right because
we have to fundamentally change how we
go to
and come home from war right and if we
change what we're going into
and we have a different end state in
mind right all right you just described
it perfectly for too long our end state
has been the world war ii model we come
in
we beat you
right we're now in charge
you like the japanese and the germans go
along with it and don't fight back
how often does that actually happen
right by the way von klaus which is how
we win world war ii we we basically
steamroll both of them right when we
actually drop atomic weapons on another
country
that's how we get these people to
capitulate
every other example that you there's a
profit incentive well
that's again that's what we have that
you're right the economics of
imperialism don't work
the way that we go to war doesn't work
uh and it needs to it needs to be fixed
this can't happen again what was the
very first thing that biden's new uh
secretary of defense did he gave a 250
million contract to raytheon right who
did he work for before he was secretary
of defense it's a revolving door how's
that okay
it's not
we're supposed to have ethics laws in
this country there was
there's supposed to be a more a ban on
you know lobbying and everything but
yeah again as you pointed out the rich
and the elite and the powerful get to
have special privileges do you think
that ever goes away yes how
no but but your strategy where you're
going to
do you think this ever goes away show a
time in history yeah that's gone away uh
marie antoinette would say it goes away
okay the
the powerful can only
sustain power
for as long as the power less agree that
they're powerless
right especially domestically i've never
in a million years would have thought
that you could shut new york city down
for two years and the new yorkers would
go along with it i never in a million
years growing up in that area i would
have never thought that people would be
like you know what
yeah you know i i'll go bankrupt it's
fine i don't mind yeah whatever whatever
it takes i know that this doesn't make
any sense wearing masks six feet apart
you know the bums on the subway they're
they're walking around doing everything
you're telling everybody not to do and
they're surviving for you but no i i
whatever whatever you say de blasio in a
million years i would have thought it
would have been a riot i would have
thought there would have been a
revolution i would have thought there
would have been people you know tarred
and feathered and ran out of town on a
pole
and it's not happening anymore it turns
out you know they said the pen was
mightier than the sword the camera phone
is mightier than the swordbed the camera
phone is the most powerful weapon ever
created people are are are so afraid
to
you know
and and i think the problem pat becomes
in this moment you you talk about law
and order a lot
then this moment it's such a dangerous
moment because the only people that are
making any sort of positive moves are
the type of people that have absolutely
no regard for the consequences of law
and order criminals autocrats
you know
what this is really going to be for
people looking back at this 500 years
you were talking about 14 19. people
that are writing about this time they're
going to say
democracy may be a great idea but as
long as there are
autocrats and dictators you may not be
able to sustain it so there's a guy
named benjamin barber who wrote a book
called strong democracy back in the 90s
and basically what he argues is that
that there's there's there's a
progression of democracy that that
coincides with the progression of of
economies right so economies go from
agrarian to industrial to
post-industrial or what we would call
basically creative economies right and
we're in a creative economy um we're
post-industrial britain's
post-industrial um
korea post-industrial japan's
post-industries yeah
um
has talked about this a lot with this is
where androgyny comes in well so what he
argues though is he says that that the
sort of the harmony state of of that we
all grew up thinking of what capitalism
and nation-state relations and democracy
should look like is the post-world war
ii environment
pre-true globalization what he basically
calls is like the
the 50s and the in the 60s and what he
argues there is that before you had
transnational corporations
economies had companies that were based
only in the united states right you had
you know disney was just an american
company ford's an american company right
so they're subject to american law and
if they want to
do business there they follow american
law they don't really have to worry
about i said no though i mean coca-cola
made fanta sell sugar water
that's but that's where he gets the
point is once you have he argues that
once you have transnational corporations
once capitalism expands they on the
borders of the nation state
transnational corporations actually
become the most powerful entity on the
planet right because they're beyond
government regulation hard to argue with
that okay so what benjamin barbara
argues is that the only way to actually
reel in the negative effects of of
rampant runaway capitalism which we have
robber barons now that's corporatism
it's not really capitalism global
federalism
no yeah no
it's the only and i'm gonna be honest
here i think that's where we move as a
species
that's what they're that's what they're
trying no the idea the idea look
you have on your list here this crap so
the problem is government so we need a
more giant global bureaucracy
you have to think of it you're thinking
of as a one government like u.n thing
and i'm talking about more like united
states of earth where xi jinping is in
charge of earth it's a democratically
elected thing okay
who's agreeing to that i'm telling you i
think that's where we move to jesus
christ
there's no way the nations to if you are
fundamentally arguing for the nation
state which has been around since the
idea of the treaty of west failure i
think at this point honestly you're
running you're arguing from a 20th
century mindset
we're beyond it we're beyond it we're in
something different disagree with you
we're
we are we are we are evo i'm telling you
right now this is where the human race
is headed whether you like it or not
this is where i i guarantee i i predict
within a hundred years
you you think there's going to be a
common language within a hundred years i
don't know if we're gonna be common
culture in a hundred years we're moving
towards one no we're moving towards
we're we're moving toward
capitalism pushes us this way no
stop it does gosh capitalism pushes us
why the efficiency the efficiency of
being able to the efficiency of one
there's no way listen let me ask you a
question how long are you going to
tolerate if i slap you on the back
really hard how many times how how often
do you if i keep doing it to you right
if i get up right now come to your back
and i just start slapping your back
really hard how many times can i get
away with it probably once okay that's
what i'm trying to say to you right but
let's just say you're like your first
reaction is going to be what
the
what's the matter with you right stop
but you're first going to say what stop
if i do it again if i do it again you
and i probably brawling over here right
okay
i don't think uh i think the history of
mankind you've always had people
that are driven by power and control and
you've had people that are driven by
freedom and leave me the hell alone okay
one group masters the art of
manipulation
the other group masters of art of
persuasion the strength of those that
are driven by power and manipulation is
they
sell their concept more because they're
better at bitching and crying and
complaining because they have more time
on their hands the weakness of those who
are driven by freedom leave me alone is
they're so occupied building something
creating something winning for them and
their families they don't have time to
[ __ ] they don't care too [ __ ] they're
not gonna go out there and try to do
anything to you but if you sit down with
them and you have the ability to reason
you can they can persuade you and say
here's why i live my life this way right
if the person is willing to pursue you
know be open to it now
historically go and look at um
religions many people will say
most religions were created to control a
populist let's just say i'm a christian
some will say you know that is a form of
you know the ten commandments to get
people to not do anything to each other
you know don't do anything to a guy's
wife and don't murder and don't do this
fine you take a hundred different
religions and you put the structure
together but ninety percent of it is
what similar things you're not get to
pick and choose you wanna be a christian
presbyterian you know whatever you want
to be similarities right there jewish
christian pretty much the same thing
christians have one other guy that came
afterwards and they think he's a jew
christians think he's a jew christians
think he is the messiah right okay
but
the ability to want to control isn't
anything new the difference is
people are a little bit more not a
little bit more wiser today the negative
side of it is we have a million and one
distractions today that we didn't have
before this is the ultimate distraction
that we have today right so where am i
going with this here's where i'm going
with this um
i don't think
you know i think there's a point where
you can't push people that are driven by
freedom too much i think if you cross
that line you're going to see a side of
theirs you've not seen before i think
that's kind of the direction we're going
right now people are rising up you're a
guy that voted for biden you go up
against them and you're willing to come
to a podcast like this and have a
conversation and we go back and forth
and the people that win today is the
audience because the audience sees us
having differences we're having this
discourse and they walk and say screw
pat screw man screw gerard or dude
gerard's my guy i agree with him i wish
adam was here pat's wrong whatever
they're gonna do but the audience is
winning right now right
my concern is the following here's what
my concern is uh uh uh
recently if we look at what happened
with coronavirus and kovat the pandemic
have you followed the uh uh what is that
uh
uh the event 201 have you followed
anything with the event 201 you followed
event 201 so if you want to pull up
event 201 just pull it up on google
uh and and i'm curious to know what
you're going to say about this so event
201 is
hosted by economic world economic forum
this is public info this is not a
conspiracy theory or anything like that
this is just something everybody knows
about so event 201 was hosted this was
in october of 2018 okay
october of 20th and the john hopkins
center health security and partnership
with the world economic forum and bill
melinda gates foundation hosted an event
201 high level pandemic exercise on
october 18th my birthday 2019 in new
york new york the exercise illustrated
areas where public-private partnerships
will be necessary during the response to
a severe pandemic in order to diminish
large-scale economic and societal
consequences this is october 18. look at
the suggestions
two months later the pandemic happened
look at the suggestions can you can you
you're on google yeah let me uh what do
you mean the suggestion they they
well i don't want i don't want to bog
down the podcast but if with this if
they go one step further yeah they gave
suggestions from their report and it was
to censor social media not allow discord
everything that happened the last two
years can you can you all right on
google go ahead and google i want you to
type in are we ready
no no not rare r
we
oh hi buddy come on are we ready uh my
name matt zeller
and then the word syracuse
okay uh yeah no i'll go back up to are
we ready
um my nightmare the experience take my
name out of it
put are we ready and then actually put
take my name out of it sorry and put
strategic
national stockpile
to circle back to what you were saying
while we're waiting yeah you know i i
think you're right right yeah
right there thanks hang on one second
okay so this is my master's thesis yeah
go ahead and scroll down take a look at
the date
oh six
all right so in 2006 this team and i
were hired by the united states house of
representatives on committee on homeland
security to evaluate at that point the
pandemic influenza response plan for the
united states and to poke holes in it
and to see whether or not it would work
and what we learned was that if a
pandemic ever hit this country we were
we were well and truly [ __ ] um is what
we had learned um
so
we we wrote this report and in our
report we don't choose it we didn't
choose a sars covid type virus we choose
something that was actually scarier
which is h5n1 so h5n1 is a bird flu that
has a higher lethality than ebola and if
it ever actually became airborne and was
easily transmissible it would be what it
would be like with the movie contagion
per trace like it would it would wipe
most of us out
we wrote it based on this the idea is
that h5n1 arrives in the united states
uh via a flight coming in from asia and
within 48 hours is everywhere
and then through this report all the
recommendations in this were actually
ended up being enacted into law by
congress
one of the things that we proposed was
regular practical exercises teaming up
private industry
like you just saw the 201 exercise on a
regular scale to try to get government
and private industry to begin thinking
about how to work through pandemics so i
mean i i don't think that there's those
types of events happened all the time
yeah but let me go back to my point here
so this is you guys just
jumped in and went to a bunch of
different directions let's stay focused
real second i'm trying to ask a question
from you because i want to know what
you're going to do
my biggest concern is
anticipation of what's coming next
because kovid ruined people's lives the
last two years i think that's absolutely
both sides would agree with your school
education kids okay we don't even know
the side effects of it for a long time
with youth on what happened today right
i mean like
my uh just my daughter yeah is home for
a year
in a half nine year old a 2009 year old
what does that do yeah to their
development in new york you're saying
yeah yeah no virginia okay in addition
to that she's been conditioned now to
see every single human being as a
potential threat to her well-being it's
very interesting you say that yeah
actually yeah yeah so we don't know what
that feels like we don't know what the
side effects of that we have no idea
what do you do with the kindergarten
exactly
and now california just announced it and
anyways california announced yesterday
they're getting rid of ella usc they've
been with us i've sent these i don't
know if you saw that oh yeah yeah they
again wrote absent these and they're
going back to indoor updates but but
here's where i'm going to so i'm looking
at world economic forum i'm like okay so
you guys did this october 18 2000 2019.
two months later the pandemic kids it's
kind of weird a lot of the stuff you
guys talked about okay let me put the
hat on being a little bit skeptic
recently they had another one i don't
know if you saw the simulation that they
did so have you heard of cyber polygon
have you heard about the cyber polygon
being ran by a world economic forum i
know of it yet okay pull that off cyber
polygon so we can look at that so cyber
polygon if you want to pull up uh
that's not the first one there's another
one you can go to cyber polygon is
a project that they're doing same thing
again they're testing to see what would
happen
if there is a cyber pandemic so they're
calling now the cyber pandemic so cyber
polygon these days as a dislocation in
the other example
in this environment the best strategy to
safeguard our future is to build up the
right skills and understand the risks
involved this is why cyber polygon 2021
was dedicated to secure ecosystem
development pat if i can for a minute
just so people know the world economic
forum is not elected bureaucracy it is a
it is a non-government organization yes
just like the world health organization
exactly so they have these great names
as if they're like the u.n as this is
some sort of elected politicians is it
this is some sort of collaboration of
world leaders it is not it is a
non-governmental organization this is an
international lobbying group that has
just
amassed so much control over our planet
i mean they the control that the world
economic forum and you know the world
health organization have over our public
policy is insane to a degree where
sometimes it feels like they're leading
our public policy but they are not
elected officials these are not
politicians these are not people that
that are representative of any people of
any government it's a very very
dangerous group but anyway so so they
just had a meeting and they did a
simulation if you want to go to the
simulation that we can read this is
reuters article go to the next one uh by
the way these guys met in july of this
year which is quite scary because every
time these guys get together and no no
you just had it imf the israel
tyler you just had it up yeah i xed out
just give me one second okay just type
in uh uh uh
imf israel
uh type in israel okay there you go okay
so exclusive imf 10 countries simulate
cyber attack on global financial system
okay and this thing lasted like three
and a half hours if you want to go up a
little bit
so jerusalem december 9 reuters israel
on thursday led a 10 country simulation
on a major attack on the global
financial systems in an attempt to
increase cooperation that would help
could help to minimize any potential
damages financial markets and banks a
simulator war game and as israeli's
finance minister called it and planned
over the past year evolved over 10 days
with sensitive data emerging on the dark
web with the simulation also used fake
news reports that in the scenario caused
chaos in global markets and a run on
banks if you can go a little lower the
simulation likely caused by what
officials call sophisticated players
feature several types of attacks that
impact the global foreign exchange and
bond markets liquidity integrity data
and transactions between imposters and
expo
exporters these events are creating
havoc in the financial markets set a
narrator of a film show so it's five and
a half hours that you can watch this
steve wozniak is in it some of the most
powerful people in the world are in it
right
do you know what they're saying would
happen if this was actually to take
place power shutdown you don't have
power no ac no phone no internet no
nothing we've already seen it banking
system
in countries no it's not it's called
hurricane called superstorm sandy if you
lived in new york
the power went down there were no atms
there were no credit cards you couldn't
buy gas how long so you could but you
could buy gas but it was thirty dollars
a gallon yeah and you had to pay in cash
right and if you didn't have cash good
luck it was a week one week it was chaos
okay how about unpack the chaos unpack
it i i i lived through it
it was i mean they're calling the
national guard it was that what i'm
saying is people who didn't live there
they don't know unpack it you couldn't
like imagine you need food right so
right now you go down to like the
grocery store you go you pay with your
card right there's no card your card
doesn't work so okay you got to get cash
well the atms are out of cash and they
don't have power to begin with so how do
you buy food you're hungry what did you
guys do like like i was working for
christy
you were working for chris christie at
the time so what did you do i wasn't
there i i was i was in new york i had
friends who were who were telling me
that they would literally
they had like rations once you eat
through your rations what what happened
was capitalism yeah people came from
other states yeah some people
volunteered other people put a whole
bunch of gas in their pickup truck from
from pennsylvania and went down to
jersey shore and was like i got gallons
of gas for 30 bucks and then there was
this whole thing and the price gouging
and the legality of it but people would
fight over like over atms like when atm
was like working and spitting out cash
they were like fist fights they would
get into it because do you know what the
wildest thing was
uh chinese restaurants delivered yeah
yeah it was nuts yeah people were
watering not everything was closed down
but but chinese restaurants were
delivered
so here's the thing man here's the thing
uh uh we were not ready for the pandemic
okay the america was not ready for the
pandemic we had no idea what was going
to happen but here's what the pandemic
did the pandemic
made the creative people figure out a
way to survive right i remember in we're
in dallas pandemic comes out
non-essential essential our business was
called not essential we still showed up
to the office okay
the pandemic we couldn't sell insurance
face-to-face because people didn't want
you to come into their house we've never
sold on a zoom we went from selling 100
of our policies face-to-face to selling
100 of our policies over zoom we had to
learn those skills right
what do you think is the likelihood of
something like when world economic forum
gets together and talks about something
like this what do you think they're
trying to say you think something like
this is possibly likely to happen in the
next 12 24 36 months
i think it's 100 likely at some point
because it's a it's a tool of warfare
who's ready who's ready for this russia
russia is ready who else is ready for
china who else is ready for this anybody
who's figured out how to disconnect
their country from the internet is
america ready for this no okay so you
think russia and china are that far
ahead of us yeah russia russia actively
practices drills where they disconnect
themselves from the internet entirely
and russia has an entire cyber warfare
division that is charged with creating
the chaos that that that that this
simulation tries to envision and we
don't we do
so we have we have the exact
digital tools are digital tools and
digital tools like everybody can imply
them the same way it's just that they
don't have as much of an interconnected
economy as we do they've figured out how
to
firewall their entire in internet right
so they can cut themselves off
dictatorship yes
exactly yeah i mean there's they have a
kill switch for the internet
and in their countries and they can cut
themselves off at any time
it
i that would probably honestly be the
first indication of a major cyber attack
coming from one of those countries is if
they cut themselves off to prevent
retaliation
really yeah
so if they if they turn their own lights
off that's the red flag it's a huge
indication that's why we probably have
to develop some type of like mutual
assert destruction worked in the cold
war for preventing us from firing nukes
at one each other we need the same thing
there needs to be some type of like
cyber mutual assured destruction but we
don't necessarily have that unless we
have back doors into their systems well
isn't this kind of the idea of space
force i mean i know everybody every you
know what i love this community in the
world
this to me is scarier than that well you
take out you take out a couple of
satellites up there and it's total
darkness sure sure but in in
in
and balloons we can we can get an
internet up like that yeah yeah yeah
yeah especially you put a high altitude
balloon with a repeater and you can
actually broadcast as a cell network
pretty high up and and put an entire
like
um internet on top of something no the
the the the
honestly the
the scarier [ __ ] is is [ __ ] up with
our ground stations and like our like
getting into the cyber so like all like
the computer systems in the country that
run like the um the the the energy grid
based off of like really really old
operating systems somebody told me
they're talking about jersey and sandy
somebody told me that if if the linden
cogen plan had gone down that wouldn't
have had power for 90 days
if i was the russians or the chinese the
very first thing that i do if i'm going
to engage in cyber warfare is shut down
the us power grid so but here's the
thing let me ask you what's the job of a
journalist is it to be to trust
everything you see or to question and be
a little bit skeptical i think it's to
report the news and you know be a little
bit skeptical you got to be a skeptic
like you're a skeptic right now you're
trying to find out what the hell
happened with afghanistan so you're
going through this commission you're
getting the guys in everybody is that's
non-current official that they don't
really care about getting re-elected
republicans eight and eight democrats
it's a fair deal to do right let's be a
little bit skeptical with this uh
uh with this uh what do you call a cyber
polygon
what what is the world economic forum
what are these powerful people who fund
something like this which by the way can
you pull up to find out who funds world
economic forum what are they worried
about now watch this watch what this
goes to when they unpack what their
fears are so the impact of the kova 19
pandemic is giving away to new
opportunities to cyber crime okay
some new methods include deep fakes
crypto currencies
and mobile wallets expect an increase in
supply chain attacks right global cyber
crime predictions for 2022 fake news 2.0
and the return on misinformation
campaign who are they talking about
probably only one guy and that's the
dummy that you're a big fan of right
that's that's president donald trump
they fear fake news 2.0 watch this
watch this
fake news 2.0 on the return of
misinformation campaigns okay
the the calm of fake news surrounding
the contentious issues has become a new
attack vector
years horizon zones
misinformation okay watches throughout
2021 misinformation was spread about
kova 19 pandemic and vaccination
information the black market for fake
vaccine certificates expanded globally
now selling fakes from 29 countries fake
vaccine passports certificates were on
sale for 100 to 120
this is on their site okay this is on
their site which by the way did you did
you get the video i sent you with mark
zuckerberg and fauci pull that up real
quick which this is coming from fauci
who is the most credible source
apparently on the topic of vaccine and
the topic of uh uh kovit here's what he
had to say if you have the video i'll
let you pull it up okay so this is the
first one in addition prior to 2022 2020
u.s presidential election checkpoint
researchers spotted surges in malicious
election related domains and the use of
mean camouflage so again
aimed at shifting public opinion in the
run up to the u.s midterm elections in
november 2022. so first of all there's
two things we learned about this so far
one of them is that cyber
polygon
uh uh event that hosted by world
economic forum their worry is fake news
2.0 which is vaccines because you know
he's right and number two is midterms
those are two things they just revealed
to us here's what fauci just had to say
on zuck by the way i don't know if you
saw this raise the audio
vaccine that looked good go back tyler
actually made okay watch this go back
all the way back this would not be the
first time that a vaccine that looked
good
actually made people worse one of the
hiv vaccines that we tested several
years ago
actually made individuals more likely to
get infected to get infected actually
made individuals more likely this is did
you hear what he just said by the way
yeah okay i've been hearing every word
that he said so yeah so he he just said
hey the vaccine you know we have a few
friends that you know they're going
through vaccine and the next you know
they get the cobit i thought this is
supposed to be kind of helping you out
well maybe there's a fake god forbid and
somebody says something so the folks
that you put youtube that monitored this
stuff and shut stuff down we didn't say
that that's your guy voucher that just
said that but let me continue the second
one cyber attacks targeting supply
chains
supply chains what do you mean by supply
chains the cyber cold war intensifies
data breaches are large-scale and more
costly mobile malware attacks increase
as more people use mobile wallets and
platforms uh payment platforms
cryptocurrency becomes a focal point for
cyber attacks globally attackers
leverage vulnerabilities and
microservices to launch
large-scale attacks deep fake
technologies weaponize penetration tools
continue okay if you want to pull up
this article here's what i read i want
to hear both of your thoughts i just
read this
is world economic forum the big guys
that get together who are funding this
say the fives are guys that are funding
they say the guys that are funding this
that they're worried a person cannot
come in and take too much control
they're worried about elections
they're worried about god forbid
somebody disagrees with them
misinformation they're worried about
what's gonna happen with the crypto
community because it's not regulated
they're worried about anybody that's an
independent thinker
and that's their cyber polygon
god forbid people can think for
themselves so what what concerns you
about something like this what do you
think about when you read something like
this well i'll start because i i'm very
interested to hear mr zeller's opinion
on this but the this goes to what you
were saying before about the the the
global federalism right to me this right
here is what they are striving for these
non-these ngos
want to take over the planet because
they're the smartest people they're the
best people they're the most noble
people eugenicists are always right
and they are going to parcel out the
world
in a fair and equitable way with them at
the top of the food chain i have no
doubt that you are right in that this is
the future that they see
i will spend my every living breath
fighting it because i i don't believe
they are noble and i don't believe that
that they are
not ill-intentioned if they were then
we wouldn't have to wait 75 years to
know what's in our our super serum
so
my thing is this i've been lied to too
much by people in power my life to trust
people in power and that's just the fact
of it i've seen too much i've been in
these rooms
and and i've seen the wizard
we cannot give these people control if
you hate donald trump then donald trump
shouldn't have control over your
medicine donald trump shouldn't have
control over your life over your
education and if you if you hated that
man then why would you want that man the
apparatus that that man controls to have
that much influence and power over your
life
and now you're gonna we're gonna do that
on a global scale i'm supposed to
believe that vladimir putin
xi jinping and and
what's his name klaus wits whatever
whatever the the the bald socialist
he care he cares guy looks like a guy
from a movie evil guy he cares about me
and my life yeah he cares about my
well-being
see these people these greater good
people they they they think they're
brilliant everybody that's ever come
before them is dumb but they have it
figured out they're gonna get it right
this time
and those are the people that kill 100
million people and then like like the
communists that you
you uh you interviewed hey you gotta you
gotta break some eggs to make an omelet
it's for the greater good well not those
hundred million people that died is not
for the greater good and the the lying
is non-stop all right well well you know
yeah we tried oh well we just shut your
life down for two years oh well you know
things happen and now facebook comes out
and they say the fact checkers right you
had zuckerberg these fact checkers it
turns out they're just opinions in court
when they finally got pressed in court
they say yeah no these are just uh third
party opinions we're presenting people
with a secondary opinion that's not how
you presented it you actually demonetize
people because our fact checkers said
so
frankly i've been lied to too much to
trust these people and i think that they
are too powerful in this moment and i'll
be honest matt i mean you're a democrat
and you're one of the good guys i'm sure
but i think that i'm just going to be
frank and i'm going to call it is i
think the democratic party's been
infiltrated by these international these
international uh coalitions and i think
that they are
no longer representing the
by and large i don't think they're
representing the american people i think
they're representing the global
community and i resent the democratic
party for that
hmm
what are your thoughts about this cyber
polygon
that was a lot
um
i i
i'm not as i'm not as worried about it
as you all seem to be i think it's just
an act for people honestly most of these
think tanks are wealthy people trying to
feel important and they they spend a lot
of time and money bringing people
together in a room to role play [ __ ]
right because they miss being in power
they miss being in charge they miss
being part of the action and this is a
way to continue to have influence in
state of the game
um
i'm sorry i talked for a long time but
it's hard to say that
and then you see build back better
everywhere
they're really yeah yeah some of them
are really good at messaging and they
get hired to do this type of stuff too
right
i i am honestly the the thing that
concerns me more is the chaos
that would be unleashed if
a nation state like russia or china
engaged in cyber warfare and i think
it's a good thing that we try to
practice and have
forums in which we bring people together
trying to think through how we're going
to manage what could potentially be a
horrific situation
here's what i would challenge you back
is if you're skeptical get involved why
don't you ask if you can join them
i'm serious like
or start your own
start your own
cyber thing to examine this and put out
your own information
uh
that that to me i think it is the more
effective thing here like again
be good capitalist give them competition
in the market for their ideas that which
i agree like
because i i i agree with you i don't
think there should be one entity that
dominates this conversation right i
think that there should be
multiple people we get to a better uh
solution if we have multiple people
working at the problem and there's
competition between
each other and they're trying to you
know come up with a better solution
because they're the ones that ultimately
gonna the market's gonna drive to
but when it comes to the chaos that
could be potentially unleased
if for example the
the gru which is the russian military
intelligence unit
that have a pretty good cyber warfare
capability uh if they were to be you
know truly unleash their cyber warfare
capability onto our economy and we
weren't prepared i mean
look kobed was a pain in the ass like
shutting down like the country for two
years has sucked right
you know how much it would really suck
if the power never came back on
like i'd rather we at least practice it
and unfortunately the elites are the
elites of the elites because they
already they are who they are and
they're going to organize themselves in
forums like this
to try to continue to have influence i
think it's up to folks like us
to challenge that influence by putting
out our own ideas by
by ask by trying to engage in and be
involved in in in their discussion so
that it's not just the same group of
people always talking and making the
decisions
um but i i i have no problem with
organizations like this trying to come
together i i i don't know how much
influence they actually have you don't
know how much influence the world health
organization actually has i don't i mean
the world economics guys the world
economic forum at davos did build back
better three years ago and all you see
all over the world is built back better
yeah it's a it's a campaign slogan for
the entire north american uh uh power
leadership apparatus justin burdos
justin trudeau stands in front of signs
that say build back better
bill there's there's a bill a three
trillion dollar bill that's being
i mean both so like let's be clear
everybody's guilty of this right if you
go to the state level in the united
states where the state level governments
right there's an organization called
alec the american legislature i gotta
look it up but alec is a conservative
group that literally writes verbatim
language that they then give to state
legislation sure sure they basically and
they basically use carbon copies like
everybody
yeah okay
everybody does it you okay but we go
from we go from they don't have any
influence to everybody has this kind of
information no i don't i don't i
honestly
dude you you are a man's man and you're
a brilliant dude be straight with me be
straight to me right now do you think
the current leadership of the democratic
party specifically is beholden to the
american people of the global community
i have no idea who they're beholden to
at this point i really don't i don't
know how to answer that question i i
honestly don't know i wish i could say
that holding the american people but
given my personal experience over the
last year i don't know who they're
beholden to i really don't i also tell
you this they have a problem on their
hands because they lost my vote
and they don't seem to figure they
haven't seem to figure that out yet
there's a sizable portion of people like
me
who if trump runs again i'm not gonna
vote for biden i'm not gonna vote for
trump and
that's a problem
they don't
they're
they have unified government this is why
i think it's so important to santos
rounds man they have unified they've
unified government
and yet they can't seem to accomplish
anything and
you're right i
they don't seem to be a party that cares
about the average american worker
anymore and i think that's honestly why
hillary one of the biggest reasons why
hillary was a terrible candidate to run
the first place considering where she
was politically in terms of how the
american people saw her right but she i
agree with you she had active disdain
for the plebeian and that's the thing
about it right is trump appealed to a
bunch of people who feel like they've
been left behind
that they've been abandoned right that
nobody has their back because they have
been right they have been
and i don't know if there is a party in
this country that speaks to those people
anymore i really don't i don't think the
republican party by the way is a party
anymore i think it's a cult it's a cult
of personality
when friends of mine like added a common
enemy when friends of mine like adam
kinzinger and pete meyer don't have a
home right when they're being just an
amish when they're being actively
primaried like adam's a great guy he's a
really he's a true america he but he's a
patriot he gives a [ __ ] about this
country right pete meyer has been a
friend of mine for 15 years
right pete gives a damn about this
country to the point that he got on a
plane and flew to afghanistan in the
middle of the evacuation trying to help
out just because he thought as a vet and
a member of congress he might be able to
get people through the gate faster like
he took a lot of [ __ ] for that by the
way for what he did because it people
called it a political stunt he was just
going over there trying to help out like
he's a guy who gives it these are all
people who are being actively targeted
because they didn't bend the knee to the
dictator and that's what frightens me
about trump this idea that if you are
i'll give you my favorite example one of
my business partners is a died in the
world republican during the 2016
election he entered the election by
bundling cash for jeb bush when jeb bush
dropped out he wrote one paper a
national security policy position paper
for lindsey graham
because he wrote a position for graham
in the primary the trump world deemed
him not politically
allegiant enough to ever serve in the
trump white house he was banned he was
banned he told me i cannot get a job in
this administration because i didn't
show enough fealty that terrifies the
[ __ ] out of me that that's such mafioso
[ __ ]
that's not how you get good governance
that's how you get nepotism what are you
what are you talking about though like
matt like the bbb uh uh you say a
comment like that you gotta look at it
on the other side as well
uh you just talked about on the biden
side you know we opened up the meeting
with
saying how come they haven't had you on
media since three four months ago they
don't want to hear the truth yeah so
this isn't a
loyalty is expected from both sides
don't get a twist this is not likely
awful i don't disagree that it's awful
but loyalty is expected from both sides
you can't just look at it from the one
side to the other side so no i also i i
listen i'm not here to listen i'm just
bringing i bring up trump because i
personally hate the guy okay and i think
he's honestly the biggest threat to this
country's long-term survivability i know
that you guys might be fans but that man
is i'm not a trumpeter i'll put it in
i'll show you the notes you can take a
look what does that say what date is on
that
january 1817 january 18 2017. these are
notes that i wrote two days before he
took office it's entitled how they take
over or if i were putin here's how i
take over
the guy
is a russian asset and i know you don't
want to hear this but i'm telling you
this is someone who used to no i worked
this is the steel door
listen it's his behavior
why is it that he meets with putin
one-on-one without translators in the
room and we never get a transcript from
it why because he's checking in with his
[ __ ] handler all right i used to do
this for a living you don't think i can
look and see you don't think i can look
across the table and see somebody that i
would have recruited he's a [ __ ] he
lost
all right so the russian playbook is all
about what's called different
disinformation compromise sure
compromising i had jack barski on two
weeks ago he's a former kgb i'm fully
aware of what you're talking about so
look at how trump then engaged with the
american people any time he was
criticized it's fake news
he went and targeted people who wouldn't
bend the knee look who got attacked
constantly by trump world mccain in
particular they went after john mccain
why because he was the only member of
the party with enough clout that might
be able to push back on his cult of
personality so what do they do they try
to go after his legacy they try to go
after and get compromising information
to him why is it that lindsey graham
flips like this lindsay flips like this
because lindsay is gayer than the day is
long and he's afraid that if that comes
out in south carolina he doesn't get
reelected that's why he suddenly goes
from being john mccain's best friend i
remember them when they were like i used
to hang out with these people i saw them
they were dear friends you're dropping
some absolute bombs right and what
you're telling me what does this have to
do with russia go back to the world i'm
telling you this is a so make your point
on russia that's what i'm curious trump
is trained to act like a russian asset
would
he's trained to take over power in the
way a russian asset if they were in
place would
look at what he's gotten us to do in
four years we all now yell at each other
we don't trust anything that was obama's
second time
but but we don't we really don't trust
it now he poured jet fuel why if you're
an american president is your job to
unite and lead this country and make it
better or is it hold on do you feel like
you came out of that presidency more
united or more divided more divided for
sure okay hold on hold on i listen to
you guys talk for 10 minutes my turn
sure all right if you feel like you came
out of it more divided let me ask you
this what is the job of the american
president it's to fight for this country
it's to make this country great again
for example you really feel like you
came out of this great you really feel
that the antimonster and the strife that
we all feel when we talk about this son
of a [ __ ] is good no this is exactly
what our enemies wanted i agree this is
putin's wet [ __ ] dream and so this is
what i come back to
i went to a birthday party two weeks
before two weeks after the 2016 election
it was a bunch of polish family they had
come here they'd grown up in poland
under communism yeah
i was standing on the back deck with the
dad
and we were talking about the election
and i asked him so what do you think he
goes do you want my honest opinion i go
yeah and he goes
you americans have no experience with
what just happened to you
this is how they take over and by the
time you figure it out it'll be too late
and it terrifies me because i loved this
country and i i it's stuck in the back
of my mind this whole time right
sentimental story but uh no matter
look look at what's fascinating
what's fascinating is i see it the same
way but i see it from a different
perspective so to me i mean everything
you're saying i agree with but i'm
saying to myself this started with
a second term
the division look i'm sorry you don't
think he's an asset look what he tries
to do he discredits nato nato is the one
thing that has kept russia in check for
70 years and suddenly he's questioning
them to pay their bills why is it that
every foreign policy thing that that man
did was in favor of putin why is it
always benefited putin that is the one
the chinese trade deal benefited putin
yes absolutely the chinese trade bill
benefits putin oh
are you kidding me no seriously all
right russia is sitting right next to
china they're part of the belton road
strategy that china wants it's an
integra they're trying to integrate a
market over there anything that benefits
china helps out russia's economy
russia is just as dependent as the
chinese as we are they don't want the
chinese economy to collapse just as much
as we don't
you you have to understand
putin is playing a much much longer game
the best way i just heard it described
is when the cold war ended we spiked the
ball at the one yard line we didn't put
our our throat you know our foot on
their throat this is a kgb officer who
couldn't stand the fact that his country
lost and he's been playing the moment
let me ask a question let me ask a
question so go back and tell us this
saint of yours that was perfect at
foreign policy who do you put as a
standard who's the gold standard for you
i don't think there's a saint in u.s
this guy so give foreign the gold
standard harry truman harry truman's
your gold standard if you were to pick
an american president that was able to
articulate i mean truman the trumpet you
hate this guy you you hate trump you
wonder why i hate you yeah i'm still
curious
people like you seem to like him are you
out of your mind are you do you know
people like me i like people like me
escape the [ __ ] of people like you
the bottom two no no no no no no no no
no no no no no the game's me and played
against guys like you're what makes this
country great and i can't figure out why
someone is smart i'm going to explain to
you why like no it's not it's not but
wait a minute you make it seem like this
is a trump podcast no it's not but like
i don't understand
forgive me yeah the way i look at him is
binary i i can't look at him and see
good things
i can look at obama and see good things
i can look at biden and see good things
i can look at bill clinton see good
things then you're better than i am it's
not about being better than you are
buddy it's it's not about that i love
america and i don't look at people
from the standpoint i've sit down with
mobsters gangsters i've sit down with
you know communists i love talking to
communists because it's a great
conversation for me i don't sit there
and say i hate this guy see the the
challenge with your side because you
sound like a broken record right now as
if it's cnn or msnbc do you know what
happened to their ratings when the world
find out found that they were full of
[ __ ] with russia go look at their
ratings go look at their ratings the
week after the world found out this
entire das here was funded by a lady
named hillary clinton what happened to
the ratings afterwards you know why
because americans were sitting there
saying we believed you
schiff
we believed you guys
cuomo we believed you
lemon we believed you cooper we believed
you and you fooled us
and now brian williams was a guy that
interviewed you says what i'm done with
this i'm worried because what's going on
to america today and he's stepping away
so for me when it comes down to guys
that come out and say things like that
about trump and russia oh my gosh like
who tell me one president first of all
let's let's put the truth out there
has this been a guy that his entire life
has been a master troll and a bully
yeah yes i don't disagree
has this been a guy that came from the
streets of new york where negotiations
are all hardcore and you gotta go
against other guys that are also
hardcore because new york's dna is like
you are this is what i like is that how
new york is yes this is new york's dna
america's not matt zeller no america is
not chris christie america is not
hillary clinton nor trump america's not
cuomo america is more tyler america is
more just a regular person that loves
his country right right okay and then
you come out and you say russia russia
russia russia russia when this guy was
president let me tell you what policies
i like i go policies if you want to talk
emotion personality you can hate that
guy's personality you can sit there and
say this guy knows the hell out of me i
know people that hate obama hate obama
every obama interview i've ever watched
whether it's with leno whether it's with
whoever i've never seen an interview
where i didn't like hearing him speak i
would say i'd love to watch a game with
this guy doesn't mean i agree with his
policies so the emotions i pull out and
i say okay let's look at policies
uh when this guy took office he was the
first guy that was not afraid of facing
off china first guy that's it you want
to do this tariff you want to do this
tariff you want to do this tariff look
where we are today these barrels that we
were getting from china that was 2500
bucks a pop now it's what containers 40
000 a container you think he will let
them charge forty thousand dollars today
hell to the no but biden says what oh uh
uh end of message
end of message what end of message
you're giving a speech on the guy that
passed away end of message
trump stood up against china trump was
willing to sit down with these guys
negotiate trump did palestine and israel
like that's ridiculous to be able to do
what he did 25 years economy was doing
good for whites blacks asian hispanics
women everybody but media hated this guy
why because he called that [ __ ] and
that's his flaw his fault his fault was
the following if somebody as an advisor
gives him a fault as the following
charles barkley said this the other day
kevin durant asked him said how come
you're not on twitter
he says you know i'm not on twitter he
says why he says because i'm old school
if i'm on twitter and people talk [ __ ]
to me i feel like it's my responsibility
to respond back that's barkley guess
what that's trump
trump needs to avoid 99 of the [ __ ]
people say to him and you just focus on
the one percent he wanted to fight
everybody and he made his life a living
kill that's on him but that's how he's
wired you that that comes with the
territory but to say the guy's a russian
asset matt i mean you can say you
disagree with his policies you can say
you know
stormy daniels mcdougall you can say
grab and buy this with the bush story
you can say all you can say mccain which
was an absolute to me what the hell are
you doing going after somebody pow this
guy served the military you don't have
the right to call out another military
person how come all these generals you
don't get along with what happened with
mattis what i get millie i get some of
these guys but what happened with some
of these other guys of course all of
that stuff fully agree i totally get it
but sit there and just put it all
blanket hillary clinton just came out
and said the following she said uh i
don't know if you guys read this or not
hillary clinton warns 2024 presidential
election could be the end of democracy
national review hillary clinton warned
that former president trump is close
poised to run for election 2024 and said
that if he wins american democracy will
suffer irreparable damages if i were a
betting man a betting person right now
say trump's going to run again i think
that would be the end of our democracy
not to be point about it but i want
people to understand that this could be
a make it or break it point if you or
someone of his ilk were once again to be
elected president especially if he had a
congress that would be doing his bidding
you would not recognize our country for
many outside observers it looks as
though trump is gearing up to launch a
campaign for 2024. 90 chance this guy's
running you know what i know he's going
to be running but
i agree with what she said by the way i
think it is if he wins it'll be the end
of our democratic we are not a
functioning we're not by the way we're
not a functioning democracy right now
people said if people
but we're not a functioning democracy
anymore on a federal level we're not
okay absolutely or not unpack unpack
that
okay so how do we begin um
you have one political party again that
is a cult of personality
okay they're they they do whatever
donald trump wants there's no party
platform anymore right there's just
whatever trump wants and i know that you
keep saying he's not a russian asset but
why did they change the right of the
republican party changed the platform at
the republican party convention in 2016
when it came to ukraine once he took the
nomination why was it that was changed
why did he try to pull us out of nato
i'm sorry you you had everything you the
one thing that you never did the one
thing that you never said to me that
explained is his russian possibilities
after all the investigations show one
proof he's a russian asset instead of
just making accusations so the proof for
example if somebody says biden daddy the
big guy 10 million dollars there is
proof okay the the new york times story
when it was blocked by twitter how much
money look at how much money he gets
through deutsche bank who do you think
funds deutsche what i'm trying to tell
you is show me the last three and a half
years
what kind of investigation could they
have done shitty businessman he can't
even get lended to by anybody else other
than the one bank that the russians
specifically fund i'm sorry like come on
stop it
you're saying he's a shitty businessman
absolutely he's a shitty business he's a
horribly shitty you're losing
credibility on that side really this
guy's a bad businessman how many of his
casinos went bankrupt how many
contractors did he never pay he's losing
his hotel in washington dc right now it
works
really how do you think business works
he had daddy's money you know they did
they figured out that if he had taken
the loan his father gave him in the 70s
and he had simply just invested in an
index fund he'd be worth 25 billion
today that's how you know he's a shitty
businessman he couldn't even keep up
with the market yeah so so so that that
just to me bleeds envy and frustration
frustration here you're upset no he's
just it's totally fine if you are upset
with the guy no when i'm upset is what
he's done to my country
what he did to your country in four
years
yes he poured jet fuel on a fire you're
you're the president united states
you're supposed to unite us who's the
last time who's the last unifier we had
in america that's a great question i i i
you know i've been thinking that for a
long time
i've been really trying to ask myself
like who would be the last and i it
probably is reagan
you'd think like maybe because like we
think about like when it's the last
landslide election
i think bill was uh i think bill was uh
able to get both sides to dylan dylan
was the contract with america fantastic
you take you take monica lewinsky take
that out that's fair okay maybe maybe i
say bill and reagan that that's kind of
the start of the the monica lewinsky
thing i think is kind of the start of
this hatfield and mccoy fight that
actually it starts with the contract
with america and the reason why is it
starts in the 94 election so the 94
election you have to understand this is
a seminal election in american history
it the the house of representatives at
that point for 40 years has been held by
the democratic party okay the senate
flipped a couple of times but the house
has been held for before think about it
yeah that's my entire life right 40
years okay it used to be the working man
party that's why so
here's what happens in 94. newt gingrich
goes around to all the republican
folks running for office that year
against democrats and he says here's the
common strategy you're going to ask the
person you're running against in the
debates can you name the price of milk
back home i remember that and
elected members couldn't and the reason
why was because the culture in
washington at the time was as if you got
elected to the house or the senate
you moved your family to dc you didn't
go back home to your district maybe
other than a couple of times a year you
absorbed into the swamp but but you you
you met people you went to the same
church together synagogue together your
kids played on the same little league
teams right your your spouses knew each
other socially
it made compromise and working together
easier because these were people that
you had personal relationships with that
you might have policy differences and
disagreements right i don't think
patrick and i are ever going to agree on
trump being a russian asset but you know
hopefully at the end of the day we can
shake hands and walk away from this
that's because that'll always be the
case yeah they don't ever i know that
but that's how washington used to be it
doesn't work like that anymore now
because now they're not there they're
there tuesday to thursday a couple times
you know a couple of weeks a year right
and then they're back home and they're
on tv and they're screaming at each
other and they don't know one or two
i'm not blaming one side or the other
i'm just saying everything changes with
that one disagree with that and it's
because it's that culture change that i
honestly think changes the americans to
link it but to link it bro to saying
trump is the guy that created the
division he didn't create it we haven't
even had this jet fuel on it to be fair
to be fair
is it fair to say
uh let's see if you can be reasonable
here i'm hoping you can be reasonable
here and take the emotions out
is it fair to say
that out of all the uh uh people that
have been elected during our lifetime
you and i are the same age i think we're
three years apart and he's two years
younger than you
four years young you're 36 or 30 30 36
36 okay so i'm 43 you're 40 he's 30
you're 40. we have 40 in january okay so
you're 39. so okay
is it fair to say the last 40 years
carter winning
reagan winning
senior winning
clinton winning
jr winning the gw winning obama winning
trump winning is it fair to say
the biggest shell shocking winner where
you were like what the hell just
happened is trump uh 100 is it even
close what do you put close to that i
couldn't
it was such a shock to my sister i
couldn't sleep that i was at 3 30 up in
the morning i'm on the phone with tom
i'm sounds like he won i said no new
york times just reported it
i said there's no hillary's
hillary's got the resume newsweek got
the magazine ready madam i know him
everybody that that magazine right now
is like priceless everybody's trying to
buy that magazine because it's so hard
it's like a limited edition product
right
we're sitting there like this guy just
won okay so imagine a guy that's an
underdog comes in talks [ __ ]
calls everybody out whether he's right
or wrong and half of america votes for
this guy so either half of america
is a bunch of idiots deplorables which
you and i agree that they're not they're
angry and frustrated i i agree and not
and they felt that he tapped into
something that he he that he heard them
beautiful it's less about him guys it
was i'm telling you it's about more
about
the to the voting against versus voting
for i don't know my entire family is
democrats and i'm telling you they're
they're gone they're off the rails they
have not voted democrat for the first
time in their lives because they do not
feel like these ivy leaguers they're
always talking above them they're always
lecturing them they're always blaming
them and it feels like these people have
the international community's best
interest in mind and not our best
interest in mind and we resent that
so that's that's where this comes from
and donald trump tapped into it he he
pulled one of the greatest he pulled one
of the greatest
illusions of all time this is a guy that
that grew up 90 floors above everybody
else with a silver spoon in his mouth
and somehow convinced west virginia coal
miners he was one of them
so i mean that that just goes to show
you how badly and honest to god matt and
this is this is kind of where where i i
see it differently than you do he took
the obama playbook the obama political
playbook and i think obama is the
greatest politician of my lifetime but
he took their playbook
and turned it on its head and ran their
playbook you disagree with me
well you're racist you disagree with me
you hate america took the exact same
tactics
inverted it and if you think that's
pouring fire maybe it is to me it's a
galilean dialectic you see somebody do
something and it works
what do you do you emulate it
so
one of the other big things that
happened for a guy like me over these
last four years i did not vote for trump
the first time i did vote for trump the
second time because i felt like
democrats did not learn their lesson
at some point they just had to be like
you know what guys
socialism is a touchy issue we haven't
we're asking for a lot of the hours of
your life and taxes and we're not really
showing our work here and there's a ton
of waste in government that we're not
addressing at all but we're just asking
you for more and more and more of your
money
maybe we shouldn't have just said if you
disagree with us you're racist that was
probably a bad tactic sorry about that
that's kind of all they had to do well
let me let me ask this question because
matt i want to go a little deeper with
you because we only got 15 minutes 30
minutes left so so at a time like this
uh you know every generation will use
the line this is a consequential
election you know because you have to do
because that creates urgency come out
vote okay i get that so script everybody
use the script it works
but uh
are enemies today bigger than they've
ever been
is is is china today scarier than what
russia was in the 80s yes yeah okay so
so is but it's not presented that way
but but but but hang on a second so is
china scarier today ji jinping you know
is he scarier today than hitler was in
his era i don't know okay
they're not fair they're not like you
know invading the student line right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i agree with
you but yeah because we don't know
thailand's over there
well i mean taiwan is terrified right i
mean they're they're doing well they're
doing airaid drills constantly and you
know the build-up of their artificial
islands and the indo-chinese sea is
obviously very very very concerning to
anyone who lives over there it's very
obvious too that china and russia
specifically iran they they don't have
any fear but you know where i'm going
with this here's where i'm going with
this here's where i'm going with this
they understand by the way that we have
our own insurgency in our hands right
now and after january 6 they understand
that we don't have the bandwidth but
matt here's my question for you here's
my question for you so do you remember
when calipari came from college to nba
with the nets he flopped he went back
and then he crushed it in college do you
remember that yeah do you remember when
carol the first time he came to the nfl
just didn't work out and then he went
back to college with usc then he won 16
six seasons in her with ten plus wins
first coach to ever do it at that time
then it comes to nfl seattle and then he
crushes it right you know how they say
some coaches do better with college
players and nba players and some coaches
are better
in nba like nick saban didn't make it in
the nfl he killed it he's going to be
probably one of the greatest coaches of
all time passes bear bryant as the
greatest coach of all time in college
football right
what kind of a president do we need
today that's what i'm trying to ask if
you're saying it's not trump if we're
saying it's not biden if we're saying
it's not obama
what kind of a president do we have
today and who's the closest thing to
that that's your opinion i'm curious to
know what you say about this
at a season like this
where america is at where china's at
where russia is at where iran is now
allies with china okay where we got
crypto community that's trying to say
listen we don't trust anybody in the
government at a time where we got cyber
world economic forum covet
what do we need
do we need today we need to tell the
entire baby boomer generation to shut up
retire and get out of the way
they're they're the problem
they don't they they don't can they
don't have any boomers aren't a problem
yes yeah they're too old at this point
look at any time you have like hearings
in congress on like facebook or like
cryptocurrency and you've got like you
know
like chuck grassley from iowa who's like
88 years old he doesn't understand any
of this right he's just reading prepared
remarks because his staff has written
them for them they have to do it we need
we need people our generation are you
saying like musk said we shouldn't have
elected officials above 70 years old is
that kind of what you're saying well i
would say we would call i'm i'm thinking
that what the moment calls for right now
is somebody honestly there's probably a
millennial somebody who understands the
goal you're ready to turn the keys over
to aoc no i i p uh people to judge it
would be if i was gonna pick a person
who would be a pizza brilliant i know
pete personally he's one of the smartest
people you've ever met he called
highways racist man
listen the democratic party has a really
weird thing when it comes to to the the
the domestic sort of politics and that
type of stuff and i don't understand a
lot of it i really don't i don't even
begin to try to get in the discussion
but if you're asking for i i'm
my response is if you're looking for a
guy or a woman a person that i can
identify right now on the national
political lands who can handle china who
can handle russia who can handle all the
issues who who doesn't need to be
brought up to speed who's smart tulsi
gabbard do you think no god no no oh my
god no
she is
listen that
that woman should not be allowed to wear
a uniform oh whoa
whoa okay
there is a fundamental
neither of you served no he did he did
all right then you understand you don't
do politics in uniform she's going on
social media in her colonel's uniform
and doing politics
that's a big no no i'm talking about
everyone's done it i get what you're
saying
all these guys do and she was an assad
apologist i will never she she no when
you go and you meet with that that man
dropped barrel bombs on children she
dropped barrel bombs on children they
dropped chlorine gas on kids no no no no
no no
she does not get in a pass
she's the only american official in
seven years who stood with that son of a
[ __ ]
if you want to have talk about values
right do we stand for something well you
don't go and stand next to assad and he
say he's a good man trying to do right
would you would you would you agree to
do a sit down with tulsi and you only if
i could spit in her face
wow i can't stand her i think she is
well that that's just not gonna work i
think i think she is
i think she is
a a complete
and and total disappointment she is she
is
derelict in her duty she is engaged in
conduct on becoming behavior she ought
to be court-martialed for what she's
done in uniform
it's kind of unfortunate you feel that
way about somebody
aren't becoming she got into a uniform
and went on so let me ask you a
different question let me ask you a
different question the easiest charge to
bring up by the way as a commander if i
was her commander i'd bring her up on
conduct i'm becoming i got i got two
questions for you and i got eight
minutes to go through this incredibly
strong picture let me go through this so
go back to uh so what are your thoughts
on hillary clinton
she was a brilliant woman
she really watched a very very smart
woman probably one of the smartest
people who ever do you think she's evil
no i think she's misunderstood
okay
you don't think hillary's evil you think
she's misunderstood strong opinions on
policy that is very weird for you to say
that i don't i i i don't think she's
evil you don't think she's evil you
think the the ukrainian ukrainian so so
by the way the audience has to make a
decision for themselves whether they
agree with your tulsa but let me go back
to pete let me go back to pete let me go
back to pete let me go back to pete so
let's say pete is your candidate because
you're you're you're a pete camp you're
definitely not a tulsi camera okay i
would have loved to have cena sit down
with you and tell us but spitting can't
go on in this podcast so let's go back
to let's go interface but i'd be i would
not be happy to be in the same room with
her okay well then that's a problem in
america by the way because i think you
know i'm trying to get obama and trump
in the same room and i have my own money
on the line because i think that's what
we kind of need to do to get people have
discourse because that's how the
american people win but it is what it is
let me go back to pete go i'll tell you
why i won't sit down with her why
because she would never say that she was
wrong
she would never say you're right do you
i'll tell you anyone i'm 100 right when
i'm wrong oh anytime i tell you all you
haven't been able to show one proof of
russian asset with trump and you think
you're right i know i'm right you
haven't been able to just prove that
i've proved i i think in my mind i have
you think so that's like so so that's a
that's like a spiritual connection you
have to an imaginary russian again acid
i i go back to pete forgive me but only
one person at this table was in the cia
and actually did this for a living and
i'm telling you right now but i tell you
it's like a doctor who gave birth to
four thousand kids saying i've never had
a kid before but i know what i'm doing i
don't know your business but it'd be
like me coming in at this point and like
you see whatever your business is
there's a bunch of people that would
disagree with me
go to pete go to pete go to p let's talk
about pete because i actually like pete
i think peter's smart i think pizza i
think peter's smart but i don't think
pete can get elected because he's gay by
the way and i think that sucks that's
this is my this is my concern i think he
can get elected in america if he's gay
in america in america but that's not the
problem hear me out let me ask a
question i want to see what you're going
to say sure
we live in america
where we have gay employees
i have gay executives it's it's not like
a thing anymore it's not like
i'm an iranian middle eastern guy that
runs an insurance company how the hell
does this make i'm not when i would go
to insurance conferences no one looked
like this guy big nose big ears iranian
middle eastern like what do you do are
you security guard or your bodyguard not
one of the ceos no way yes okay cool i
guess america lets people like you also
make it to the top fine i like that
but if you go with pete and pete's
sitting there trying to negotiate with a
north korea or negotiate with a
china or russia to them do you know how
they still look at the yeah the gay
community do you know how iran and saudi
and a lot of these guys like so you
automatically lose two billion muslims
that you can't necessarily negotiate
with so i don't think a guy like that
would be good for foreign affairs
because they would not negotiate they
would laugh at a guy like peter not in
america i think they would that's
assuming he's not on paternity leave
i think by the way i think paternity
leave should be for everybody i think
it's a good thing that's not a pandemic
no no
the most important thing that we can be
doing is developing good humans agreed
okay well the most important stage of
development is the first three years of
your life it's when your brain is most
malleable
by the way it's why i believe that the
scandinavians have it right you should
have two years paid to stay at home with
your kids and take care of them how many
years two the wife or uh both parents
i know you i know you think this is
crazy but think no but think of this
from a speciological development oh my
gosh think of it man you mean to say me
and my wife we stay home for two years
to take care of the kids yeah think of
it thank you speechless oh my gosh
i hate to laugh at you i'm just i'm
entertained right now you're a man of
your time right you're a guy who's been
brought up in a culture in which you
would you know and i think this is the
biggest pansy era of all time okay
for most of our species development we
didn't live in houses right we were
hunter-gatherers okay sure
you're talking the reason why we all get
fat right now is because we eat foods
that we weren't evolved to eat right we
didn't evolve to eat complex
carbohydrates and breads right that's
why ketosis and all that [ __ ] works okay
so
think about it from the hunter-gatherer
perspective you're out there you're on
the planes right
men is out foraging women are foraging
whatever right
but kids
kids are constantly with their parents
pretty much all the time they're being
taken care of right they were back then
back then okay okay that's how we
evolved what i'm saying is that the idea
now that you were born and then you're
handed over to a daycare infrastructure
or to a nanny or to somebody to watch
you in the most important part of your
brain's development
and you're away from the two people you
have a biological can you you have kids
right four of them okay so when they
were born the first thing that you do as
a dad is you hold them to your chest
right so the kid imprints on you okay
that's so important and it's not just
that one time it's two years of that
gosh
if you want better formed humans if you
want better people who are better
participants in democracy i'm telling
you you have your opinions on that so
that's extreme because to me i think
humans were stronger and tougher back in
the days i think we're getting softer
and softer and softer and we're raising
pansies today if you ask me we're
raising softies today if you ask me
we're raising people that can't be
offended god forbid you say something oh
my gosh i failed oh my goodness let's
get rid of the f because it hurt my
feelings what am i going to do people
going to laugh at me yeah we're raising
pansies today so
i think my dad and iran work six days a
week in iran friday is here sunday
and i love my dad
more than you would even know he's my
best friend he lives with me i saw him
once a week and i'm totally okay with
that
and i was raised fine he taught me the
right values and principles and i think
even back if you're going to go history
even further back
men used to leave and come back and they
wouldn't see their family for a long
time the longest longest lifespan
of any culture on the planet and the
happiest highest standard of living is
in scandinavia
and the one thing that all those
countries have in common is that they
all provide at least one to two years of
paid subsidized maternity and paternity
leave at from the major economies the
longest lifespan is actually in uh japan
and and they have a very different way
of living life they build businesses
they teach toughness they teach the
right values and principles and the
largest lifespan longest lifespan like
how long people actually live in a
country that's not considered one of the
top countries is monaco it's 89 and a
half japan is 85 monaco's 89.5 but i
know we can tell a lot of statistics to
sell scandinavians are doing it right i
can only imagine two years for me to be
home with the kids that's probably not
healthy for my wife and kids
that's why you don't want to do it you
don't want to be there no no no no no i
don't think it's good for the marriage i
think my wife would say stay go to work
probably yeah so anyways matt regardless
of what happened the one thing about you
bro that you got to know that i respect
a lot
is we talk we chop it up and you're
going to be invited back i have no
issues with you i enjoyed the combo we
still haven't talked about the biggest
story that no one's talking about
then you got to come back
what is it
where the hell is flying up in the sky
that no one knows
what they are that that to me i don't
understand yeah
we got we we've got we've got our uh
we've got baltis and maverick here two
people invited they took
one was in europe one was in california
took pictures of the same thing at the
same time the government admits we don't
know what these things are they're not
our technology they're not any other
known technology they are russian assets
no no they're not they're russian assets
i wish
you know what it'd be it'd be less
frightening if they were right because
they violate the fundamental laws of
physics yeah and we don't know what they
are it's the biggest story and everyone
just kind of collected went ah
yeah
like why isn't this something we talk
about every day like there are things
that violate our airspace
get closest to our most technologically
advanced aircraft and naval you know
equipment and personnel the things that
are guarding our shores
and we go i don't know what they are i
don't know how they got there i don't
know how to stop them that's a good
point it's terrifying i agree i agree
well i don't know maybe that's what we
talk about next time
tulsi gabba we put a glass in between
you guys
do you really know chelsea of course if
you can get me into chelsea i will not
spit on her but you got to be respectful
bro i would be respectful with her but
she needs because she by the way here's
one thing about tulsi she's going to see
this and she's going to say something if
she responds she loves them she is she
is not going to say if you want to have
an opinion take off your uniform i'm
serious if you see this i don't know
what camera am i looking at take off
your uniform
take off your uniform i'm saying this to
you as one fellow officer to another i'm
not sitting here doing this in uniform
right now right take off your uniform if
you want to continue to have an opinion
you swore an oath like the rest of us
how dare you that's why and and by the
way apologize for meeting assad you met
with a war criminal it's like standing
next to hitler and being proud of it you
see tulsi in a bikini she looks pretty
good when she takes off her uniform
listen tulsi is somebody that makes a
lot of sense and has a lot of loyal
followers so it's going to be
interesting to see what happens there
but anyways matt good to have you i
appreciate you uh we'll have you back on
uh to talk about some of the stuff that
we didn't get a chance to get into but
aside from that folks this is the first
week when we're doing podcasts today
with zeller tomorrow will be with john
eaton i believe who is the lawyer
representing xrp ripple going against
the sec government he's going to break
the whole the whole xrp community is
going to be here tomorrow and then
thursday the great daniel de martino
booth will be here so we're going to do
back to back to back this week three
days man appreciate you for coming out
bye this was great thanks for having me
thanks guys bye bye bye bye bye
that was awesome
you